what is happening reject nation it's
correct Alka here and it's John Humphrey
over here and it's Matt Matt beard from
that movie guy is his YouTube channel he
is actually one of our most loyal
patrons supporters and in town City
Wednesday yeah every video I have said a
different spot of the world he is from
this was gonna be my last time I make
that joke and you just took it from me
I'm sorry I take two I'm sorry Matt I'm
sorry I'm sorry
we were watched today from how it should
have ended villain pop penny for your
fears
speaking of villains John and I I wore
this shirt on our jigsaw horror comedy
sketch this is an awesome shirt that I
actually wore once to a party because
from the company T no evil they sent
over these shirts to us and I got to
tell you guys have some awesome shirt as
we bought some other shirts from that
before I love that they keep sending us
these cool shirts and return all we have
to do is tell you guys to go check them
out them out and the reason I wear these
even outside of film is because these
shirts are look how cool this shirt yeah
these are sick ass tees and every time I
wear this shirt how people are
complimenting me and they actually asked
me where do I get them from and I say
you don't want to know because I want to
be the only one wearing this shirt but
today I'm telling you guys Teno evil.com
busy you guys ready I am so ready
[Music]
spoo comes ledger here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah it's some children of the corn
[Music]
why so glum you look like you got beaten
up by a bunch of kids with baseball bats
I did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
have you tried scary dolls dolls always
work well until your personality gets to
candy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here's a real problem you've got to
follow food because now that you've
heard old Palpatine's feelings over
there he's not gonna let you do that
again
go on try as far as it is you can't just
keep playing with your targets it's easy
to get them scared at first but
eventually they're gonna get wise and
turn the tables even though you've got
in your face beaten in by a bunch of
little children and it's totally
embarrassing there is one you horror
monsters always have
[Music]
[Music]
where's Billy the puppet I don't know
yeah what's up Billy the puppet might
have been in there are these like
strictly 80s I think have a Gorgon from
stranger things that are at the end oh
yeah these are all his 80s references
well that was really fun
that was funny yeah I kind of wish we
could see a real-life version of this
hey Diller yeah I love the idea of like
the heroes meeting in the cafe and then
across town yeah those were all the
villains right
I love mashups like these four
characters are just commiserating over
the workplace drunk about being a bully
who's your favorite 80s villain go my
favorite Leatherface I'm still around
the 80s though never samples were
churning out yeah I'm trying to think of
like a tease I guess Michael didn't
because I was really mostly in the
eighties like 79 then my GF would say
Jason I would go with the Terminator
what I loved was that moment where it
was just the exoskeleton of the
Terminator and at Arnold's voice I wish
the movies would do that that's how he
brought back a terminator whatever this
new Terminator is with you staring at
that's the best way to keep him around
forever and they use get an Armin
impersonator to take over anyway
subscribe to how it should have ended
check out more videos somewhere in the
world you can check out Matt beer on
that movie guy channel follow us on
social media
good day America peace be with you